[Music]
this video will teach you how to inject
your insulin using a syringe please
watch the entire video before injecting
your insulin your healthcare provider
may recommend that you inject insulin
using a syringe to help you control your
blood sugar level injecting insulin with
a syringe involves choosing an injection
site preparing the syringe and insulin
and then injecting the insulin into your
body your healthcare provider will tell
you what type of insulin you need as
well as when and how much you need to
inject you will need alcohol wipes your
bottle of insulin a new syringe for each
injection and a sharps disposal
container to throw away the used
syringes a disposable syringe has the
following parts a barrel a plunger a
needle cap and a needle selecting the
injection site before injecting your
insulin select the injection site on
your body the areas for insulin
injection include the abdomen or belly
upper arms the thighs and the buttocks
when selecting the injection site be
sure you use a different spot each time
you give yourself an injection
leave at least one inch away from the
last injection spot inject your insulin
at least two inches from your belly
button and choose a spot one inch or
farther away from any scar or mole
preparing the syringe and insulin step 1
wash your hands with soap and water and
then dry them step 2 if your insulin
needs to be mixed gently roll the bottle
between your hands do not shake the
bottle because it may cause bubbles to
form in your insulin before injecting
yourself check the insulin in the bottle
to make sure it is the type of insulin
your doctor prescribed for you not past
the expiration date and the insulin is
free of clumps step 3 remove the cap
from your insulin bottle use an alcohol
wipe to clean the rubber stopper on the
top of the bottle
step 4 remove the syringe from its
package be sure to use a new syringe
each time you inject insulin step 5
remove the needle cap from the syringe
do not touch the needle or allow it to
touch any surface and do not use the
syringe if the needle is bent some
syringes have a cap over the plunger
that you may need to remove as well step
6
pull back the plunger to draw in an
amount of air that is equal to your
insulin dose
step 7 hold your insulin bottle securely
on a flat surface push the needle
through the rubber on the top of the
bottle push the plunger to inject the
air into the insulin bottle leave the
needle in the bottle this helps to keep
the right amount of pressure in the
bottle and makes it easier to draw
insulin into the syringe step 8
with the needle still in the bottle turn
the bottle and syringe upside down step
9
pull back the plunger to fill the
syringe with just a little more than the
insulin dose you need if you see air
bubbles tap the barrel of the syringe
with your finger to make them rise to
the top slowly push in the plunger just
enough to push out the air and extra
insulin step 10 carefully check to make
sure the amount of insulin in the
syringe matches your insulin dose pull
the needle out of the bottle and
carefully lay the syringe on a flat
clean surface make sure the needle does
not touch anything
injecting the insulin step 1 clean your
injection site with an alcohol wipe use
a circular motion to clean a spot about
two inches wide step 2 pinch a 2-inch
fold of skin in the cleaned injection
spot step 3
hold the syringe like a pencil and
quickly insert the needle straight into
your skin at a 90 degree angle make sure
the whole needle enters your skin step 4
push the plunger all the way down to
inject the insulin into the fat tissue
beneath your skin slowly count to five
before removing the needle to make sure
you have injected all of the insulin
step 5 pull the needle straight out to
remove it step 6
throw away the syringe into your sharps
disposal container never throw your
syringes or needles directly into the
trash contact your healthcare provider
if you have questions about injecting
your insulin or if your blood sugar
level stays above or below your target
range